MATT GOODRIDGE: OK, good
afternoon everybody.
My name's Matt Goodridge.
I'm a product manager on the
Managed Google Play Store.
That's Google's enterprise
app management platform
and app marketplace.
So hopefully it's
not too much longer
before you guys get some beers.
But for now, you're
stuck with me.
So a quick show of hands,
how many developers have we
got in the room?
Awesome.
Well, we're going to have
some code samples for you,
so hopefully that will
keep you entertained.
So whether you're an ISV, so
an independent software vendor,
or an enterprise developer
or a development agency,
this presentation aims to give
you some tools and techniques
to make the best out of
your Android development
in the enterprise.
First of all though, why
are we investing in mobile?
Well, mobile is now
becoming a significant part
of most enterprises'
digital strategies.
And let's actually look at
some data as to why is mobile
so important.
Well, first of all, it's about
increasing sales and revenue.
It's about improving
employee productivity,
and then decreasing costs.
And there's many other
reasons for it as well,
but those are really
some of the top ones.
Then in terms of
Android, Android
is the biggest
operating system in
mobile across smartphone
devices today.
And that extends
into enterprise.
68% of mobile devices shipped
through an enterprise channel
were Android last year.
And Android has a huge range
of devices that it works on,
so everything from a smartwatch
to smartphones, tablets.
And then recently
last year we've
announced Android apps
running on Chrome OS.
So you've now got Android
apps running on laptop devices
and on large screen devices.
So Chrome OS version 53 and
beyond on selected models,
and then all Chrome OS devices
launched from this year onwards
will be able to
support Android apps.
So if you're thinking about
developing on Android,
this is a really good time.
So let's also have a look at
the nature of mobile apps.
Well, although hybrid-type apps
and web-type apps on mobile
are inherently
cross-platform, actually
what we see in
enterprises is they
continue to develop
on the native platform
itself, even though most
enterprises are cross-platform
in their nature.
So they have employees
that are using
iOS as well as Android devices.
So we are really going to focus
here on native Android app
development.
And then in terms of how do
those Android apps actually
interact with other
services, well,
when we surveyed
developers, we found
that the vast majority, well
over 90% of Android apps,
are actually part of a
bigger software solution.
So they are communicating
with a cloud back end.
So we're going to assume for the
purposes of this presentation
that that's going to
be the architecture.
So that's just structure
this session briefly.
So we're going to talk
in three sections.
First of all we're
going to focus
on some aspects of design.
Then we're going to talk about
building Android apps, and then
finally deploying those
apps out to enterprises.
We're going to talk about
some critical best practices.
And a lot of these have got
much more detailed documentation
available on the web.
I'm going to show
a bunch of QR codes
in the corners of the slides.
You can then use those to
look up that documentation.
Some of them are
things like video links
which you can go and have
a look at when you're back
in the office.
So first of all, let's
talk about design.
Why does it matter you
spend time on design?
From an enterprise
perspective, it's
about cost of your operations.
Huh, what you mean cost?
Well, we've seen that mobile is
about increasing productivity.
And if that's the main reason
that you're rolling out
your apps and
services to mobile,
then there's a few things
that we need to think about.
Those apps need to be
quick for the employees
to use, which means
the lower time cost.
They've got to be easy to use
as well so that you don't need
to have support
or lower support,
and minimal training required--
again, lower time cost.
So if you don't carefully
invest in design
when you're building
your app, you
can actually risk missing out
on some of the key benefits
that you set out to
when you originally
decided to go mobile.
So how can mobile really
benefit your users?
We're going to
focus, first of all,
on how you can use all of the
sensors and peripherals that
are built into modern
mobile devices.
Because those are really going
to help your users quickly
get information into
apps rather than having
to type everything manually.
So mobile devices have a wealth
of sensors and peripherals.
You've got cellular
connectivity as well as Wi-Fi.
You've got GPS location.
You've got motion sensors
like a gyro and accelerometer.
You've got proximity
NFC for swiping badges,
Bluetooth for local
connectivity, but also
potentially indoor location
using Bluetooth beacons,
cameras for QR codes,
augmented reality, microphones
for things like
voice recognition,
a flashlight or torch, depending
on which side of the pond
you're from, for providing
light and then fingerprints,
which make your security
workflows, your sign
in workflow much slicker.
So let's just look
at a few examples
to illustrate some
opportunities here.
Sometimes it's some really
very simple things that help.
In this example,
British Gas have
added just a light function
to their meter reading app.
What they realized
was gas meters
are often in dark places.
And having that
light quickly to hand
when they're entering in
the meter reading actually
made it much quicker
to read a meter.
So let's just look
quickly at the code here.
So the light on a
smartphone is actually
part of the camera module.
And there are multiple camera
modules on many smart devices.
So you need to then
iterate through those
and identify, well, which is the
camera module that the light is
associated with, and
then switch that on,
and then returning the state
back to the calling method
so it knows that I've found
the light to switch on.
You could also be a little bit
more ambitious with something
like augmented reality.
So here's an example
from the marine industry,
helping mariners add
important information
about local shipping.
So to get started with
augmenting reality,
one of the things that you
need is a fixed reference point
in order to match the image
overlay with the image
that you're getting
from the camera.
There's a really, really
good reference point,
which is gravity.
Gravity is always pointing down.
And conveniently,
Android provides a sensor
for the gravity vector.
So you can look at or
you can get the gravity
sensor from the sensor
service within Android,
create a callback
method which then,
for each update of that gravity
vector that the sensor is
taking, you can
extract that vector
and then use that to update
your overlay over the image
that your camera is taking.
And then of course we need to
enable that callback method
by registering it as a listener
for updates from the gravity
sensor.
And then finally
I want to give you
an example of an
internal app from Google
called Google Fixit.
Fixit is used by
Googlers in order
to report problems
with our building
facilities and IT equipment
that's around our buildings.
As you can see from
this screenshot,
before I've even
entered a location,
it already knows that
I'm on the 10th floor
of the building I was in
when I took the screenshot.
And when I then start
to enter the exact room,
it will autocomplete for me.
So there's three things
that we really need
to get that kind of experience.
Number one is get the location.
Secondly is to look up against
a series of points of interest
that might be interesting
in your application,
and then of course
do the autocomplete.
I'm going to focus specifically
on the location piece
because that's the mobile bit.
The rest you'll probably
already be doing in the cloud.
So on the location side, there's
really two techniques for this.
Android already keeps a
regular poll of your location.
So you can just look up the last
known location of the device.
But that's sometimes
not entirely accurate
because it only does that with
a relatively low frequency
in order to conserve
battery life.
But it might be useful
if you know your user has
been stationary for a while.
It's also very quick because
that location is already
stored in memory.
The second approach
is then to start
listening for location updates.
So this is then activating a
particular location provider.
In this example, I've got GPS.
And as you probably
know, it takes
a little while for a GPS
chipset to actually acquire
a good fix of satellites.
So you can start
sampling location updates
and then provide
those location updates
to a short method, which can
then determine for you which
is the most accurate take.
So for this particular
example, one way
to get a combination of accuracy
and a good user experience
is as soon as the user first
clicks into the autocompleting
text field is to first call the
get last known location method.
So you can get
something quickly,
responsively for the
user to start typing,
but at the same time start
sampling for a new, more
accurate location.
And as your user
is typing, you're
anyway updating your
autocomplete list.
You can also be using an
updated location in parallel
in order to refine that list,
and therefore minimizing
the amount of time that
your user needs to spend
when entering this information.
So we're going to change
gears now and talk
about some techniques
for building your app.
The first one, of
course, is security.
So I could probably spend
most of today talking
about security on Android.
And there has already
been a number of talks
about that this week.
But let's just structure this,
and then we can focus down
on a particular area.
So I've got three
areas here-- first
of all, platform security.
We harden the Android platform
against direct attack.
Ecosystem security-- we're
providing security updates
for device OEMs.
We're also putting in
a lot of app scanning
and other tools
within Google Play
to make sure our users are
confident that apps that they
are installing are safe.
And then finally, the apps
themselves, your apps,
need to be themselves
free from vulnerabilities.
So Adrian Ludwig, our
security director for Android,
spoke yesterday.
And he really focused
on numbers one and two.
So I'm going to focus
here on some techniques
that you should think
about in number three,
really making sure
that your apps are
free from vulnerabilities.
So the top three things--
if there's just three
things you think
about when securing
your app, these
are the three that
we recommend--
firstly, making sure you're
using only secure network
protocols; secondly, using the
default local storage that's
provided by Android; and
then thirdly, checking that
the device is authentic
and uncompromised
when you're running on it.
There's a full list
actually at this QR code
here with extensive
details about how
to further secure your apps.
Let's just go into a
few more details though.
It might be stating the obvious,
but we see this time and time
again that apps are
still communicating
to their back ends
in clear text.
So let's just reiterate this.
Securing and encrypting
your app's communications
to its back end is absolutely
critical in protecting data
in transit.
The most effective
way of doing this
is to tell Android to stop
your app from actually
using clear text protocols.
And you can do that in
your app's manifest.
You can simply set up a
network security configuration
to ensure that cleartext
traffic is not permitted.
This is particularly
important when
you're using third party SDKs.
You can set up development
processes internally
to make sure that you
are yourselves writing
SSL-based communications.
But if you're using third
party SDKs that might also
be communicating to
some back end, enforcing
this here will mean
that those SDKs also
can't use cleartext protocols.
If you're using
Firebase for your app,
then that already uses
secure protocols back
to Google's back end.
While on the subject
of secure protocols,
you should also be aware
that many enterprises
use content proxying as another
measure to secure their data.
The way that works is
that the enterprise
would deploy a SSL certificate,
a custom certificate,
on the device, and use
that for the SSL encryption
to the proxy.
And then the proxy back
to the service back end
would then use the
service's own certificate.
So in that case,
you're effectively
man in the middling
your own app.
Since Android Nougat, we've
made some security changes such
that Android actually ignores
those custom certificates
and lets an app
explicitly opt in.
So here you have, in
the manifest then,
a way to actually
opt in for that.
If you're a development
agency or you're
an internal
enterprise developer,
then actually finding
the list of domains
that you need to whitelist
is probably straightforward,
and that list is
relatively small.
So you can set up a
whitelist a lot like this.
If you're an ISV and potentially
using or distributing your app
to many customers, then
that list of domains
is going to be very, very long.
So you should consider
enabling that for all domains.
And you can set that
as a base configuration
within your network
security policy.
Obviously that opens
things up a little bit.
So the way the
enterprise can then
resecure that to make sure
that we haven't introduced
any additional
security holes there
is to use device
management where
they can restrict and manage
which certificates are actually
deployed to the device.
So let's move on now to
data storage on the device
so Android uses a sandbox
execution environment such
that all of an
app's data is only
available to that app itself
unless it's explicitly shared.
Also from Marshmallow
onwards, we've
required the device
storage encryption
to be implemented as standard.
And if the device is managed by
an enterprise mobility manager
or device management
system, then that actually
might being required by policy.
Also in Android
Nougat and beyond,
we can also use
separate encryption keys
for work data versus
personal data in storage.
And we're going
to talk about data
separation in a little bit.
On external storage
then, external storage
is globally readable
and writable.
It's not part of that sandbox
execution environment.
So you really shouldn't store
any sensitive information
in that area.
Also an administrator might
set policies to actually block
the use of external storage.
So you should certainly
have a fallback position
if you do need to use that.
Also if you do
need to use it, do
make sure you perform input
validation when reading back
from that external
storage as you
would for any other
untrusted source of data.
And then finally,
how do you know
that the device that
your app is running on
is not vulnerable
or compromised?
Well, the SafetyNet
Attest API, which
is part of Google's
mobile services,
provides that capability.
It examines the software
and hardware information
about the device that
you're running on,
and it attempts to match
that software and hardware
fingerprint against a
set of known fingerprints
that Google maintains.
It does basic device
integrity checking,
and it also can check details
about the APK, your app, that's
calling the API as well.
And then you can send
that bundle of data
back to your server to interpret
to make sure not only is
the device uncompromised,
but the app
that's calling your
server is itself the app
that you expect it to be.
You might have caught
Ed Cunningham's talk
earlier this afternoon,
which is Google Security
Services for Android.
If you didn't get a
chance to see that,
then do catch the video.
He goes into a lot more
detail about how this works
and how you can implement it.
Also there's more
details at this QR code.
So let's move on then
to single sign-on.
Many, many companies
use single sign-on
to enable their users to use a
single user name and password
for many software services.
It's been a feature of web-based
services for a long time,
but getting a slick experience
within a native mobile app
has been pretty
challenging until now.
So here we're
assuming that there's
an enterprise authentication
server in the back end,
and you're potentially using a
third party identity provider.
So today, a user first of all
needs to enter an identifier
when they log into this app.
Particularly if
this is an ISV app,
the app itself
doesn't necessarily
know yet which identity provider
it's going to go back to.
So when they enter
their username,
the app and the service
back end is then
going to use that to determine
which identity provider to make
the authorization call back to.
Then once that's done,
the identity provider
will present the login screen.
The user needs to enter
their username and password,
and they're in.
But then they have to
do the same for one
for each individual app
that uses those credentials.
Wouldn't it be great if
mobile SSO could actually work
the same as it does on the web?
Well, the good news is it can.
And once you've got
an established login
session for each app that
the user starts using,
they can go straight in.
So there's two steps to that.
First of all, we've
got to determine
which SSO provider to use.
And then we're going to use
a feature of Chrome, Chrome
Custom Tabs, in order to
persist that login state,
and so that all apps which
are using the same technique
can share that login state.
So here's quickly how that
identity provider resolution
works.
So we're going to start off with
an enterprise mobility manager.
So the device is
under management.
That's going to send a
login hint field down
to the Android app.
Now this should start to
sound familiar if you've
implemented SSO on the web.
We're going to talk
about exactly how you
get that configuration
down to the mobile app
a little bit later.
So the Android app's
now got this login hint.
This is probably
the user's username.
The app can then send that
down to the SaaS back end
and then onwards
to the auth server
and determine which is the
identity provider to use.
The identity provider will then
present the login screen up
to the user.
Now if you configure
the auth server
to pass that login hint directly
into the username field,
then that username field
can already be prepopulated
for the user, and all they have
to do is enter their password.
So then let's talk about how do
we persist that login session.
So we're going to use
Chrome Custom Tabs.
But let's first talk about what
exactly is a Chrome Custom Tab.
It's a secure context, so
that it can load any web page,
but that host app can't
actually inspect its contents.
Users can see the
server address,
but they can't edit it.
And the cookie state is
shared between any instance
of a Chrome Custom Tab
and indeed Chrome itself.
So that's how we're going to
get our persistent login state.
It's a system browser
activity, so you
don't need to worry
about a user having
to navigate to another activity
and then come back again.
It's been built in to
Chrome since version 45.
So it's been around
a little while
and is almost guaranteed
to be on the Chrome version
that you're running on.
And it also works from
Android Jelly Bean and beyond.
In this example, I show
you Google accounts,
but you don't
actually need to be
using Google accounts for this.
This will work with any
supported identity provider,
whether they're using
OAuth or OpenID Connect.
So the good news is
the OpenID Foundation
have put together a library
called the AppAuth library,
which encapsulates
all of these elements
and does a lot of the
heavy lifting for you
so that you can quickly pull
together your authorization
step.
That library is available for
Android and iOS, and as I said,
it supports OAuth2
and OpenID Connect.
The Chrome Custom Tab
then is built into that
and it uses the shared
Chrome cookie jar.
But it will also fall
back to a default browser
if Chrome just happens
to not be available.
So what that means is we can
completely simplify the SSO
offering, making
sure that users don't
have to be continually logging
in using their username
and password.
And you can also implement
more consistent session expiry
policies without causing
a really big UX headache.
Don't forget though, we
need to enable the app
to accept that login
hint configuration.
We're going to talk
about that in just a bit.
So head on over to
GitHub.com/OpenID.
There's also a video
here which goes
into a lot more detail over
the course of half an hour
where it will give you the
details of how to implement
that and some of the gory
details of how it really
works in the back end.
So let's move on now to
talk about Chrome OS.
So you've probably heard
already that Chrome OS now
has started supporting
Android apps for Google Play.
What's actually happening
in the background
is Chrome OS includes now a
fully CTS compatible instance
of Android running.
And it's actually
Android Marshmallow
that's running
currently within Chrome.
And for the most
part, apps just work.
But of course, there's
a set of optimizations
that you can make to
make the best use out
of a Chrome device.
And we'll go through
each of these.
So first of all, we've got to
ensure that it's compatible.
For the most part, it will be.
But there's a few things that
you've got to bear in mind.
First of all, Chromebooks don't
necessarily have a touchscreen.
So the best way around this
is to make sure you explicitly
state in your manifest that
you don't need a touchscreen.
But of course with a
trackpad or a mouse,
the Chrome device will
actually implement
what we call fake touch.
So you still have that
similar kind of interaction.
And you should handle then
those differences at run time.
The other thing worth
pointing out here
is that things like GPS,
accelerometer, and gyro
are often also not included.
So don't require
those in your manifest
as a static requirement.
Rather handle their absence,
if they are absent, at runtime.
Of course on a Chrome
device, whether you've
got a laptop or a
large screen display,
you've got a lot more screen
real estate to play with.
Have a look at how do you
reflow your app, for example,
from what is probably
a single column
layout on a smartphone
to a multiple column
layout on a much larger device.
What this means
is that your users
are able to use a
lot more of your apps
functionality without having to
scroll backwards and forwards.
Also, things like opening menu
items or menus by default--
this means that your features
are much more discoverable.
Also you need far fewer
clicks for the user to access
that functionality
Chrome OS has
multiwindow support.
The Android apps in
Chrome OS lay out
into various different
sizes at the moment.
And very soon they'll be able
to do full variable window
scalability.
But for now, there
are three layouts.
There's portrait and landscape.
And they're very much the aspect
ratio of a Nexus 7 or Nexus 9
device, and then of course
full window mode as well.
What you need to do
is make sure that you
test your app in
these various modes,
and particularly
the transitions,
to make sure that your app
is reflowing and looking nice
as it does so.
So let's talk a little bit
about keyboards and text entry.
Well, text entry and things like
point and click with a mouse
will just work.
But when your users have
got a physical keyboard
in front of them, they will
expect keyboard shortcuts
to work.
You should add
keyboard listeners
to either your
activities or your views
in order to provide that kind
of functionality for your users.
In this example, I've
taken one of my activities,
and I've actually overladen
the onKeyUp method,
looking for Control-P. And
then I call my print method.
Bear in mind though
that if there's
explicit key combinations
that you're not handling,
make sure that then you're
passing that onKeyUp
method back up to the superclass
in case that's handling it.
Chromebooks have started
coming with styluses.
For example, the new
Chromebook Plus and Chrome
Pro from Samsung, those styluses
are not actually Bluetooth.
They use a different technology.
But they behave in Android the
same way as a Bluetooth stylus,
and they're accessible
using the same methods.
So the way you handle these is
through handling motion events.
You can use motion events
and their constants
to actually filter for
the different actions.
In this example, I'm explicitly
filtering for a stylus
and an erasure events.
What that means is I can be
felt doing particular actions
with a stylus at the same time
as having different actions
for finger touches.
So you might, for
example, allow the user
to be drawing with the stylus,
but then panning and zooming
with the fingers, which actually
gives a very tactile kind
of user experience.
The styluses are double ended,
so you have a drawing end
and you have an erasing end.
The other cool thing--
and you'll see this in my draw
method at the bottom here--
is there's two other parameters
that come from a stylus--
the pressure that
the user is applying
to the screen, and also
the tilt of that stylus.
So you can get really,
really creative
with what you can do with things
like drawing and other input
techniques with that stylus
that you can't actually
do with finger-based touch.
So let's now talk about
developing on managed Android.
So over the last few
years, Google's introduced
a comprehensive suite of device
and app management features
into both Android
and Google Play.
We're working together with 21
enterprise mobility management
partners, including
companies like AirWatch,
MobileIron BlackBerry, SOTI,
and of course Google Mobile
Management which comes
as part of G Suite.
There are two
management modes that I
want to discuss here today--
first of all, the
work profile, which
is predominately used in a bring
your own device or BYOD model.
Here, work data
and personal data
are kept separate in two
separate Android profiles.
And apps and notifications that
are running in the work profile
are then labeled with the
orange briefcase badge.
The fully managed
mode is typically
for devices which are
owned by the enterprise.
And they give administrators
full visibility
of what's going
on in the device,
including some deep inspection
techniques like process
logging, remote bug
reports, and forensics.
Across both of these
management modes,
managed Google Play is
used to distribute apps.
We're particularly proud
of the work profile.
In the work profile,
IT administrators
can be confident that
the data is secure.
They can set policies
to ensure things
like copy-paste doesn't
work from within a work app
into a personal app.
So it really is like having
two separate devices.
At the same time,
the IT administrator
can be confident that they're
not coming into contact
with the user's personal data.
This can be important
for compliance reasons,
particularly in
regions like the EU.
On the user's side,
they can be confident
that their employer isn't
spying on their personal usage
of their own device.
And if the user leaves
then, leaves the company,
the IT admin just
removes the work profile,
and the rest of the
device is left intact.
So from a development
standpoint then,
the fully managed device
mode doesn't actually
present any additional hurdles.
The apps just work
exactly the same way.
But in the work profile,
there are a couple
of things that you should
be aware of to make sure
that your app supports.
So first of all,
handling intents,
and then secondly sharing
data with other apps--
so similar to the
copy-paste example,
an IT administrator can block
different kinds of intents.
And it's very difficult for you
as a developer to know up front
which intents are allowed
and which are blocked
and which might be resolvable
within the work profile.
The best way to check that
is to call resolveActivity
for your intent before
you try and fire it.
And that means that if
it doesn't resolve--
and this method returns
null in that case--
then you can handle
that gracefully
rather than the intent
going into nowhere.
On the sharing data side, don't
use file URIs for sharing data
when you hand off
to another app,
because file URIs are
not going to resolve
in the other profile.
Instead, rather use content URIs
and grant explicit permission
to the destination app
to access that data.
You can find a lot more
detail at this QR code
if you're interested.
So I briefly mentioned
managed configuration before.
Have you ever had the
experience of having
to configure a complex
application as a user,
something like a VPN client
or even something as simple
as a mail client?
Sometimes there's a series
of complex parameters
that the user might
have to enter.
And this can lead to
expensive support calls
if not done properly.
Managed configuration
allows you to set those
remotely and automatically.
And it's supported for both
the fully managed device
and indeed the work profile.
One thing to bear
in mind though is
don't send credentials
using managed configuration.
So how does that work?
Well first of all,
we're going to set up
the schema for that
configuration within the app's
manifest.
So when you publish
it to Google Play,
that's then going
to read the manifest
and then make it available
to the enterprise mobility
management server, which
can then present the user
interface to an IT
admin, who can then
send that configuration
down to the device.
So let's just see an
example of that in code.
And we're going to go
back to the SSO example
that we talked about
before, and see
how do we add that login hint
field into the configuration.
So as part of the
manifest, you can
add a restrictions.xml file.
Actually the Android APIs
talk about app restrictions.
But we talk more fully
about this feature
in managed configuration because
it isn't just about restricting
the behavior of your app.
Here you can see a
number of parameters
that we need to provide
for each data field.
And of course the login hint
here is going to be a string.
Then of course you
need to get the values
within your app at runtime.
This is straightforward to do.
You just need to call
the restriction service.
And then using the key, login
hint out of the key-value pair,
you can get the value for that.
Also bear in mind that
the IT administrator
might send new
values to that field
while your app is running.
So you should also make
sure you can handle updates.
The way to do that is to
set up a broadcast receiver,
when will handle the broadcast
intent sent by the system
when new app configuration
comes down to the device.
And then of course
register that receiver
to receive that broadcast.
The thing to bear
in mind here is
you can't do that
statically in the manifest.
You have to do that
dynamically by registering
the receiver at runtime.
You should also be aware of a
industry organization called
the AppConfig Community.
AppConfig was set up by some
leading enterprise mobility
management partners.
And they're working with
developers, mobile platforms,
and others in the
ecosystem to build out
common best practices to enable
apps and mobile management
to work well together.
Google is working with
AppConfig to lay out
the Android guidance.
There's also a special case
of fully managed devices
which is for single use devices.
Things like kiosks, ruggedized
devices with barcode scanners,
ePOS terminals, and
interfaces to large equipment,
all examples of
single use devices.
And in those cases,
you don't want the user
to be able to go back to
Android, the Launcher,
to Settings, and do
other things with it.
You want to just work with the
single app in front of you.
As of Android Marshmallow, we've
introduced a new capability
called lock task mode.
In Lock Task mode,
the user can actually
escape the app that is
locked to the screen.
You can also stop the device
from switching off the screen.
So you've always got an
attractive display switched on.
Things like Home and
Recents button and Settings
are all hidden.
So the user can't
tamper with the device.
It really is locked down.
So how do you
actually enable that?
Well first of all, the
actual devices themselves
need to be under management,
so through an EMM or enterprise
mobility manager.
That EMM needs to
whitelist your app
with the system to make sure
that the app is authorized.
Then once that's done, it's
actually very straightforward
to lock your app to the screen.
It's worth though checking
that your app is actually
whitelisted.
So checking this
isLockTaskPermitted
will actually check
that the EMM has
been through that
whitelisting process.
And then you can invoke
the lock task mode.
The thing to bear
in mind is when
you're testing, make sure it's
easy to unlock the app again.
Because we've seen it
time and time again,
developers locking the app to
the screen and then not being
able to unlock it without
rebooting and loading
the app back onto the device.
So as an example
here, a company called
Teem, formerly EventBoard, are
using this on Android devices.
Teem have a meeting
with management app,
together with tablets
or kiosk devices,
to manage meeting room
bookings and other things
around the meeting room.
It's solely for
meeting management,
so they've locked
that app to the device
to avoid users from
tampering with anything else.
Teem actually use a combination
of the single use APIs,
like lock task mode, together
with the Android Device
Management APIs.
So they don't need to
use a third party EMM.
They have the solution
end to end together.
And Teem provides all
of that functionality
within their own
management portal.
So let's move on
then to deploying
your apps into enterprises.
One of the big challenges
here, if you're
using a home built
enterprise app store
or going through
an EMM potentially,
is you have to enable unknown
sources in order to allow
those apps to be deployed.
Unknown sources allows users
to download and install apps
from any source, not just
potentially the enterprise app
store that you want them to.
This can be a major
security risk.
Also, it is difficult
to push apps to devices
without user interaction.
Very often we've
seen that users have
to accept that
push install, which
can be frustrating
for admins who
are trying to get apps
to users very quickly.
Also, there may be other apps--
for example, the
consumer Play Store--
which is there which is allowing
the user to install apps
in an uncontrolled way.
So we've introduced management
capabilities within Google Play
to provide an enterprise
app store for users.
IT administrators are
able to curate the app
store for their
users, laying out
those apps into
clusters and pages
to enable easy discoverability.
The IT admin is also able
to whitelist explicitly
which apps are allowed
within the work space
and which are not, ensuring
the security of any data
in the work profile or
fully managed device.
But the question is, well why
really work with Google Play?
And this slide is
probably being seen
at least-- this is the
fourth time, I think,
during this conference.
But this is really the
critical part of it.
Google Play is a secure
source of applications.
We've been collecting
data about potentially
harmful applications for
the last two years or so.
And the data is really
quite remarkable.
If you split that data on
potentially harmful application
infection rates by those devices
that are solely getting apps
from Google Play versus
those that are getting them
from other sources,
you see a factor
of 20 difference in
the infection rate
from potentially harmful
applications or malware.
And those results are very
consistent, as you can see.
So unknown sources really
indiscriminately opens up
devices.
And we really recommend using
Google Play as your enterprise
app store, as well as
obviously it's a great consumer
store as well.
So why else?
Well Google Play as a platform
has a number of big benefits.
Firstly, it's secure.
We're using strong
authentication
with encrypted delivery of
those apps down to your device.
And those apps are all signed.
And we're making sure
that any updates of apps
are signed by the same key
as the original app itself.
We have a global
server footprint.
Urs talked a lot about
that this morning.
We use patch updates rather
than sending the whole APK down
for every update.
We only send down
the differences
in a compressed format.
That significantly reduces
bandwidth requirement and also
battery.
We do APK scanning
to making sure
that those APKs, your apps,
are free from vulnerabilities.
I'll talk a little bit more
about that in the next slide.
We provide comprehensive
publishing tools.
I'm also going to talk more
about that in a minute.
Reporting tools,
things like seeing
how quickly is the app being
installed out to users,
crash reports, and so forth.
And updates are
deployed automatically
in a sensitive way to both
battery and bandwidth.
On the management
side, we enable
IT admins to curate that store,
as you saw in the screenshot.
Push installs and
managed configuration
we've already talked about.
And there's actually no
need to use Google accounts.
We've got the ability to
work with any identity
provider with Google Play
without having to create
separate Google accounts.
And of course we've
got a full set of APIs
which your favorite
EMM can integrate into.
So let's just quickly
look at that APK scanning.
If you went to Ed's
talk earlier today,
he would have talked a lot
more about this in detail.
The thing for you to
consider though is you
don't necessarily know
what SDKs and what
versions of those that
your dev teams are using.
This isn't about scanning for
malicious intent necessarily.
But it gives you an early heads
up to legacy versions of SDKs
that might have vulnerabilities.
You remember all the PR around
the Heartbleed vulnerability
a couple of years ago where
legacy versions of SSL
were being used
across the internet,
causing complete chaos.
We are able to detect all
of these vulnerabilities
on this slide today, and
we're adding to that list
all the time.
Also about rollout management--
Google Play now provides
a comprehensive suite
of rollout tools, things
like alpha/beta testing.
You can create groups of
users for early versions
of your app, which will
then roll out automatically
to those users using the same
update mechanisms that Google
Play uses for regular updates.
But that then protects
the rest of your user base
on the stable
production version.
Once your alpha/beta version
is ready for prime time,
you can then use controlled
percentage rollouts
in order to slowly ramp
up the number of users
that you have on that version.
And you can hold that at any
time if you have problems.
You can also publish
at a particular date.
We've also just launched a fully
managed app releases process
where you can really define
a release at the beginning
of that flow and then take
it down through alpha/beta
and production.
And you can watch a great
video by a colleague of mine
at this QR code.
So if you are an ISV
or an agency developer,
you can just start straight
away by registering
for a Google Play Developer
account at this URL.
All you have to do
is pay a $25 sign
up fee, which is a one time fee.
If you're an IT department, you
need to be working with an EMM
that we've partnered with.
Here is a selection
of the 21 EMM partners
that we're currently
integrated to.
I particularly
want to highlight,
since we're here
at Google Cloud,
how you set this
up with G Suite.
So if you're not already using
Google Mobile Management,
you'll see this little pop
up, Set up mobile management,
in the front panel of the
administration console.
Once you've signed up to that,
then within the administrator's
role-based access
set up, you can then
create an administrator
with the ability
to upload private apps to Play.
If you want to
publish public apps,
then there's nothing
else you need
to do for your administrator.
Then for that admin, sign up
to for same Google Play account
we saw in the previous slide.
And then if you want to set
up private applications, which
are restricted to your
business, then you'll
see this Restrict
distribution section,
which you can just check.
And actually this is an
example of, yeah, my company.
For agencies, you can
get delegated access
to your customer's
developer account
so that you can
manage the publishing
and update flows on their behalf
rather than having to send them
APKs for them to upload.
Google Play's role-based
access mechanism
allows your customer
to then delegate
access just for your apps
rather than them having
to be concerned potentially
with you interfering with apps
that they're
publishing directly.
So that was a lot of
content we've been through.
But let me just try
and summarize that.
I think what we've
shown is that Google
has a comprehensive set of
products, features, and tools
to really help you get started
with publishing Android
apps in the enterprise.
Remember to carefully consider
your design to make sure
that you really do get the best
out of your mobile deployments.
Don't just port your
apps from desktop.
When you're building, build
with security in mind first.
Get consistency
across your fleet
by not only supporting
Android but also
optimizing for Chrome OS.
And enable management to
have your app deployable
in a largest number
of situations.
And then finally,
deploy using Google Play
for secure, reliable, and
manageable deployment.
I also want to
highlight that if you
want to sign up for
more information,
please go to this link where
you can sign up for a newsletter
and further information
about everything
we're doing in connected
work spaces and mobile.
[MUSIC PLAYING]